struggled James
how are you here are you nice to see you
let me ask you a quick couple of
questions would you mind real quick I
apologize I have to run to him no I
understand do you regret parading your
family wielding weapons on your
Christmas card uh why would I regret
taking a family photo with my family and
exercising my constitutional rights they
gave the right to life surely outweighs
the right to bear arms your constituents
would say that
um
come see house yeah I've got to run and
do it quick I'm gaining but I'll be
right back
so does the right to life I weigh the
right to be aren't
you Mr Ogle why did you take that
picture down from your Facebook feed
why didn't you take it down in the wake
of other mass shootings if it was bad
taste now was it not bad taste then